en Guatemala resta una semana para
elegir presidente alcaldes diputados al
congreso y diputados al parlamento
centroamericano en la carrera por la
presidencia hacia el Palacio Nacional
hay tres grandes opcionados de acuerdo
con los sondeos la más conocida de
Sandra Torres ella es candidata por el
partido une fue antigua primera dama de
la nación y en dos ocasiones anteriores
se presentó también como candidata
presidencial pasando a segunda vuelta en
el 2015 perdió contra Jimmy Morales y en
el 2019 contra el actual presidente
Alejandro yamatei otra gran opción hada
es Suri Ríos hija del fallecido dictador
Efraín Ríos montt ella representa a dos
partidos la coalición valor unionista la
hija del militar golpista trabajó 16
años como diputada en el congreso
también se quiso presentar en dos
ocasiones anteriores a la presidencia
pero fue de Tajo inhabilitada por el
tribunal supremo electoral y edmon
mulett es el tercer candidato que
completa esta terna de los más
opcionados él representa al partido
cabal y tiene una larga trayectoria
política y diplomática también fue
congresista por doce años presidente del
Congreso embajador de Guatemala en
Washington y en la Unión Europea y
subsecretario de las Naciones Unidas de
manera que este próximo 25 de junio 9
millones 300.000 guatemaltecos están
citados a las urnas en un país donde más
del 50% de la población vive por debajo
del umbral de pobreza y cientos de miles
cada año se ven abocados a migrar hacia
los Estados Unidos